who's at the University of Michigan hand
the floor to you you've got your 15
minutes
then there's the discussion
get this queued up yeah so I'm I'm Ben
I'm a postdoc at the University of
Michigan in the school of public policy
I'm really excited to be able to share
some of this work and continue this
really great set of conversations we've
had so I'll be talking about a paper
that was published last year or earlier
this year in computer law and Security
review and sort of picks up you know
yesterday Helen kicked us off with this
question of what are the Notions about
Humanity that are baked into Ai and this
paper and this talk is really thinking
about a related question of what Notions
about Humanity are baked into our
policies and regulations pertaining to
AI and the central argument is a
critical one showing that our current
approach is to regulating AI with
respect to sort of the role of the human
is flawed and represents a pretty bad
approach for ensuring values of equity
and democracy
so the broad background of this work is
thinking about specifically the use of
algorithms in public policy on the one
hand there's sort of these hoped for
Promises of accuracy fairness and
consistency through the use of
algorithms but on the other hand there
have been lots of controversies around
errors and bias and inflexibility and
sort of the doubts about whether
algorithms are actually appropriate to
be using and incorporating into
high-stakes decision making in
government which leads to this important
policy question of how can governments
improve public policy using algorithms
while at the same time preventing the
harms that are often associated with
these tools
so one of the mechanisms for answering
this question that many Regulators
across the world have turned to is this
idea of human oversight of the decisions
rendered by humans so when you talk
about human oversight this isn't sort of
any form of people being involved in
overseeing AI but specifically human
oversight at the level of specific
decisions about individual people
so to give a flavor for what these
policies uh mean one one recent version
of this comes in the European
commission's proposed AI act from last
spring they write for high risk AI
systems human oversight is strictly
necessary to mitigate the risks to
fundamental rights and safety posed by
AI
similarly a recent Canadian directive
describes that decisions likely to have
high or very high social impacts cannot
be made without having specific human
intervention points during the
decision-making process and the final
decision must be made by a human so
there's this idea that we can have
algorithms that are providing
recommendations and predictions as long
as the final decision there's a human
sort of intermediating between the
output of the algorithm and the actual
decision you know should this person be
released before their trial should this
person receive benefits and so on and I
was really drawn to these this the
emergence of these policies as someone
who had been doing several years of work
in experimental work looking at human
algorithm collaborations my PhD was in
computer science and the core of that
work was a set of experimental studies
looking at how people interact with
algorithms in practice and sort of the
broad theme of these papers is that
people respond to algorithms in
idiosyncratic ways and often ways that
introduce new forms of errors and biases
that wouldn't be detectable just from
looking at the algorithm in isolation so
I was particularly struck by the sort of
differences between what I was Finding
in my research and what all of these
policies were saying about human
oversight being this great corrective
for the flaws of AI
so I'll start by talking about what
these policies actually say uh and as
this project I looked at 41 different
policies from across the world and these
really break down into three different
categories of human oversight
um that I'll sort of describe in order
from least to most stringent in terms of
how they describe the role of the human
so the first approach that you're
probably all most familiar with is this
idea of restricting solely automated
decisions the canonical example here is
article 22 of the gdpr which writes that
data subjects have the right to not be
subject to a decision based solely on
automated processing
and this was really the first strategy
that was introduced and I think the
easiest to critique uh the sort of
issues uh around you know the idea that
well this introduces a very simple role
for the human right if the human can
just be sort of a check box uh very
simple process that's not actually
providing input so I'll spend most of
the time talking about these other two
approaches that in part have been
responses to the relatively
straightforward critiques to this first
approach
the second approach is to require human
discretion in some ways this is sort of
the same idea as the first one but is
putting the emphasis on the importance
of human discretion this comes up in
particular with a lot of the guides for
high-stakes risk assessments for
instance so in the guide to the compass
pre-trial risk assessment tool the
guidance says that staff should be
encouraged to use their professional
judgment and override the computed risk
as appropriate so the important thing is
that the human is not just there at all
but that they're using their discretion
to decide whether or not to follow the
algorithm's advice
and the third approach is really the
most recent one to have taken off
particularly in response to concerns
about some of the issues of sort of
putting the human in a very culpable
role and that human not actually being
able to use their discretion uh fully so
there's this idea of meaningful human
oversight and one example of this comes
from the uh article 29 data protection
working party providing guidance on the
gdpr specifically in reference to
article 22 writing that to qualify as
human involvement the controller must
ensure that any oversight of the
decision is Meaningful rather than just
a token gesture
and so typically this idea of meaningful
oversight involves three mechanisms that
are suggested the first is that people
should have the ability to override the
algorithm so that's quite similar to the
second approach the second is that
people should be able to understand the
algorithm so we want to have
transparency and explanations to ensure
that the human overseer actually
understands what's going on and finally
that people should avoid relying to
avoid relying too heavily on algorithms
we don't want them just agreeing all the
time with what the algorithm says they
should be incorporating other pieces of
information and other considerations
than just what the algorithm suggests
so the next question is to look at do
human oversight policies actually work
there's a lot of many Advocates of Human
Rights and Equity with respect to AI are
really pushing for this idea of human
oversight but I was really drawn to this
question of does this actually work if
it uh doesn't work then we sort of end
up in the worst possible situation where
we've passed a bunch of regulations so
we think we've addressed many of the
problems but in fact the human oversight
as a mechanism is failing to address the
concerns that we want to actually deal
with
so uh in the paper I talk about two
Central flaws with these policies the
first being that human oversight
policies are actually not supported by
empirical evidence so I was drawing a
lot here on my own prior work as well as
much of the other experimental work from
other HCI researchers and some of the
empirical evidence about how judges and
other Government Street level
bureaucrats are responding to algorithms
in practice and the broad takeaway from
this is that our current empirical
evidence pretty much calls into question
all of the assumptions underlying human
oversight policies
so the first the first major point is
that simply giving people discretion to
ignore or override algorithms does not
necessarily improve outcomes
so across a wide range of domains
there's long-standing research showing
that automated decision support systems
can alter human decision making and
unexpected and undesirable ways the most
notable example of this is automation
bias right that even if people are not
required to follow an automated system's
advice they tend to overly trust that
system uh simply because they sort of
believe that it's right and they reduce
the amount of attention and scrutiny
that they're otherwise putting into the
decisions
but then the broader issue that comes up
with these predictive algorithms is that
people are actually quite bad at judging
the quality of algorithmic outputs and
determining when to override those
outputs so in experimental research I
found that people are often incorrect in
terms of determining you know when they
should override the system which
direction they should override in favor
of and often introduce new racial biases
into the outcomes that result from these
systems
and even when you look at in practice
there's a number of studies that show
that judges are often overriding
pre-trial risk Assessments in ways that
are leading to much higher detention
rates than would be expected and are
also increasing racial disparities in
pre-trial release
and unfortunately even when we turn to
these ideas of more meaningful human
oversight the problems don't disappear
although the these ideas seem to suggest
okay well maybe we can you know fix
those issues with human discretion by
making that discretion more meaningful
but that's actually really hard to do in
practice
so if we think about the three different
tenets of meaningful human oversight the
first is the idea of being able to
override the algorithm as I described in
the previous slide that often doesn't go
very well the second is that okay well
what if we introduce explanations or
transparency to help people better
understand the algorithm
most research shows that this doesn't
actually improve human oversight what it
tends to do is increase human trust in
the algorithm even if the explanation is
incorrect or even if the algorithm is
incorrect explanations are often giving
people increased trust that the system
is correct even when it's not
and then our goal of having people not
rely too heavily on the algorithm is
really hard to achieve not the issue is
not just automation bias but also that
people tend to overweight the factors
that are emphasized by the algorithm so
if you give people making pre-trial
release decisions a risk assessment that
emphasizes the likelihood of recidivism
then people are likely to make decisions
that are based more heavily on that
factor of risk relative to other
considerations that they would be
balancing out that recidivism concern
with if they weren't given the algorithm
and so these first set of flaws lead to
a second issue which is that human
oversight policy is ultimately tend to
legitimize flawed and unaccountable
algorithms in government there's really
two Dimensions here that I think are
quite Salient the first is how human
oversight provides a false sense of
security and adopting algorithms if we
look at some of the key cases pre-trial
risk assessments and others you have
legislatures and judges describing why
it's okay to use these systems because
of human oversight essentially saying it
would not be allowed if we didn't have
human oversight but it is allowed with
the human oversights we have this false
sense of security that we're protected
from errors and biases because of this
human
and then the second issue is around
diminishing accountability for
institutional decision makers that
because we're assuming that the human
overseer is able to correct for errors
and biases the blame when something goes
wrong tends to fall on those individuals
so we can't we say the algorithm wasn't
the problem was not the algorithm the
problem was that the human overseer
didn't do the correct job of identifying
and correcting for issues so it
essentially means that the algorithm and
the institutional leaders and developers
are kind of released from scrutiny and
blame because we have this other quality
control mechanism that we can point the
finger to
so happy to talk through some examples
of how that plays out
but then the real question is what's the
alternative right we don't want to
Simply say well human oversight doesn't
work so let's get rid of the human and
just let the algorithm operate
autonomously the whole reason we want
the human oversight is because we don't
trust these algorithms in practice
so what I argue is that we need to move
away from a framework that sort of
thinks about this spectrum between human
decision making and algorithmic decision
making and just tries to find the right
balance and instead come up with a
broader strategy for thinking about when
do we incorporate algorithms into
decision making and how do we make those
decisions
so what I propose in the paper is a
shift from this idea of human oversight
to a broader model of institutional
oversight uh thinking about not just is
there a human in the loop affecting
these decisions but how can we increase
the burden on government agencies to
better justify their decisions to use
algorithms at all and make those
decisions Democratic and publicly
accountable helping to shift some of
that political emphasis away from this
this human overseer towards the agencies
and the political leaders that are
actually choosing to implement these
systems in the first place and put much
more of the discussion and oversight
there rather than on this idea of the
just putting the algorithm in place as
long as there's oversight
so I think about this in two stages as a
process the first would be having a
stage of really requiring a government
agency to better justify why they want
to use an algorithm what sort of
benefits they think it could achieve and
whether or not the human algorithm
interaction could actually work as
desired and then subjecting this type of
justification to democratic review and
approval before an agency is actually
able to use these systems in practice so
really shifting much of the discussion
of oversight Upstream to the larger
institutional processes of whether
algorithms are used at all
so I'll wrap up by just highlighting two
lessons uh that come from this work and
two open questions that I think are
particularly relevant for our
discussions here
the first lesson is about our need for
AI regulation but it's really important
to think about how do we develop robust
regulation that is not you know sort of
translating our values into rigorous uh
socio-technical regulation that's really
grounded in how these systems work how
they're creating harm and practice
and for both design and regulation what
I argue this means is that we can't just
be looking at algorithms as isolated
technical instruments but instead need
to think about how they're being used in
practice how do people actually interact
with these systems in practice and
really designing for those interactions
and regulating with an eye towards those
interactions
so I think about this in terms of
shifting from this concept of the human
in the loop which really centers the
algorithm to an idea of algorithm in the
loop systems where we're really taking
the human decision-making process as the
primary mode of emphasis and recognizing
that the algorithm is just an additional
input into that process we're not sort
of focusing on the algorithm as the main
thing that we care about
so two broader questions that come from
this work one what is the political
salience and effectiveness of the human
as an antidote to fears about harmful AI
when we sort of want to talk about
bringing in the human does that is that
an effective strategy or do we risk
essentializing and romanticizing the
human as a tool of political rhetoric uh
and then more broadly what are the
principles for determining the
appropriate balance or combination of
human and algorithmic judgment in
decision making how do we think about
the different values and benefits that
each of these different modes bring to
bear is their particular strengths so
thanks for your attention looking
forward to the discussion and connell's
talk
foreign